[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Huge, warm
applause for Chef Mourad.
Thank you for coming.
MOURAD LAHLOU: Thank you.
First of all, before we start,
thank you for having me again.
It's always nice to come
here and make the drive
and see the beautiful campus
and the beautiful people here.
How many Moroccan
people are in here?
None.
So this is so
awesome because I can
say whatever the
fuck I want to say,
and nobody is going to
hold me accountable.
No.
But before we start, Marty
is one of my best friends.
And I've known him for a long
time, and he works at Google.
So I've been
getting the insights
on what goes on on
the campus and how
life is for a chef on
the campus as opposed
to the restaurant world.
He's been with me on Iron Chef.
He's been with me
when I wrote the book.
He was very instrumental
in recipe development
and recipe testing.
So thank you, Marty.
And it's so fitting
that you're here today.
And also I want to give
thanks to Chef [? DeMare. ?]
He's the fellow in the back.
He was responsible for putting
this whole demo together
and all the ingredients,
and he did a great job.
So thank you, [? DeMare. ?]
So to start off, I just
want to talk a little bit
about Moroccan food.
When I was growing
up, I had no intention
of becoming a cook or a chef.
I had no idea how to cook.
And I grew up in a regular
family, traditional family,
with a lot of people
living in the same house.
We were, I think,
12 or 13 people.
And basically, the women
did all the cooking.
The men did all the talking.
And it seems like it
worked for a while.
But when I came
here, it turned out
that there was a lot of
reasons why that was going on,
and I started to understand
the importance of food
to these women that I
grew up watching cooking.
My parents got divorced, and my
mom was living with my grandpa,
so she spent a lot of
time in the kitchen,
and she did a lot of cooking.
And I felt really bad
for her growing up,
so I spent a lot of time
sitting next to her.
But I had absolutely
no desire to cook,
or I never understood
the importance of what
she was doing to my family.
I grew up in one of the
most dysfunctional families,
but it was the
food that actually
made us stick together.
It was the glue that made
everybody in the family,
no matter how much
they hated each other,
come together to the same
table, the same round table,
every day, three times a day.
And that was the best therapy
that we could have asked for.
But when I came to the
States, I came here
to become an economist
and work for a bank
and make a lot of money and
go back home and support
everybody.
[CHUCKLES] But that
didn't pan out.
So when I came here,
I was really homesick.
And I started calling
my family almost
on a daily basis until one
day, a few weeks later, when.
I got the phone bill
from AT&T. And it
was so humongous, I was
like, fuck this shit.
I'm not going to
call them everyday.
So I had to come up
with a better way
of connecting with my family.
Because I was really homesick.
I didn't speak English.
I didn't know anybody.
I didn't have Marty
in my life back then.
So it was pretty lonely.
But the best thing that
I could come up with
was reconnect with my
roots through foods.
And that's when I started
to pay attention to food.
And I was really
weirded out when
I saw people eating
in their cars
while driving to work,
people sipping coffee
and walking to wherever they--
nobody took the time.
I realized that food
in America was mostly--
I'm not generalizing, here--
but it was mostly fuel.
You put it in your body,
and it keeps you going.
If you're tired,
you drink coffee.
It gives you the impression
that you're not tired.
And then when you eat, you
just put a bunch of calories
in your body, and it
gives you the energy
to burn while you're working or
doing whatever you want to do.
But I realized that in Morocco,
it was a little bit different.
It was actually a social event.
You go, and you eat
because you want
to connect with people, even
if you feel like arguing.
And we used to argue a
lot around the table.
And it was a ritual where in
the morning, we would wake up.
It was frantic, chaotic.
My mom, my grandma,
my aunt, would
go to the kitchen earlier.
Make breakfast, pancakes,
coffee, tea, butter
and all that shit.
Put it on a big table, and then
we would all gather around it.
But we were arguing
like a Jewish family,
like you guys have
seen them in movies.
We argued during breakfast.
And what we'd do
is we'd decide what
we were going to have
for lunch every day
while we were having breakfast.
And then when breakfast is
over, the kids go to school,
the grownups go to work,
people stay at home to cook,
and then grandpa
will go to the market
and get the vegetables and
the meats and all of that.
And every day is the same
story, where people debate
what they want to have for
lunch, and then he listens,
and he goes to
the market, and he
gets whatever the fuck he
wants and brings it back
and dumps it.
And he goes away, and
they have to cook it.
So in a way, it was the
ritual that we had every day.
But I never understood
how important
that was, those interactions.
No matter how dysfunctional,
brutal, combative
it can be sometimes.
It was really important that
we would go through that.
And that's why I
got into cooking.
So I finished my master's
degree in economics.
And by the time I was done,
I had this really huge fear
that if I went on to go get
a PhD or go work for a bank
immediately, I would be
forced not to cook anymore.
And that's when the fear
settled in, and I said,
well, I'm going to just open
a restaurant for three months.
Open it.
At least I'm going to
have a place to go eat.
And then I'll go back to
doing the big boy things
that I was supposed to do.
Opened my first restaurant
with about $3,000.
$3,700 that I had on my account.
And that was in '96.
And I never left.
So I stumbled on
this thing, and it's
been the best thing
that happened to me.
And as Scott said, I have never
worked for any chef before.
I've never worked in
any kitchen before.
And you can see from
the way I dress,
I'm not the conventional
chef with the white and the--
I mean, you've known
me for a long time.
So I just try to
have fun with food.
I don't try to take
it too seriously.
What we do is very technical.
And the process that I went
through to get to this point
is teaching myself from memory.
So I never had the
guts or the courage
to call my mom or call
anybody in Morocco
and ask them how
to make something,
because they will be
pretty much saying,
why the hell did
you go to America
to learn how to make pancakes
or learn how to make couscous?
You could have stayed here, and
we would have made it for you,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So I would literally sit
there and relive the moments
that I spent in the kitchen,
watching them make stuff.
And that was a
double-edged sword.
Because on one hand, it
allowed me to make stuff
from my own perspective, from my
own vision and my memory of it.
And you literally-- I realized,
you can taste food in your head
before you even put
it in your mouth.
You literally can taste it.
And I would sit there,
I was like, yes.
She was telling me
about my fucked aunt
and how she got divorced and
the kids were blah, blah, blah.
And then she put the
onions in the pot.
Then she added some spices.
It looked kind of yellow, so
it must be turmeric or saffron
or something like that.
So I would relive those
moments, and from there, I
would make the food.
Obviously, the first couple
of times, it was disastrous.
It literally was awful.
But I just kept on going.
Because first of
all, I was so broke
that I couldn't go to
restaurants and eat.
And second of all, it
was the only way for me
to really stay connected.
And that's how the
journey started.
But obviously, you guys
are interested in food.
And I hope that
somehow, when you cook,
you have some connection to
wherever you're coming from
and wherever you're going
and things like that.
So the food that
I end up making--
so I came here when I was 17.
And I've been here
for a lot longer
than when I was in Morocco.
So the food that I make now
is a reflection of who I am.
So the roots are in Morocco.
So I use a lot of ingredients
or techniques from Morocco,
but obviously, I use a lot
of things from the Bay Area,
especially from the
Bay Area in California.
And as Marty can attest
to it, sometimes when
we cook together,
really, the line
is so blurry as to
what's really Moroccan
and what's not Moroccan.
But once we find that
spot, that sweet spot,
where the two cultures
or the two cuisines
merge harmoniously,
then it becomes
something that is bigger
and better than both ends.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Has your
family tasted your food?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Yes.
It was really cool.
Because after I started
cooking, I finally
brought my mom from Morocco.
And for three months,
I was telling my staff,
this little Moroccan
woman is going
to come and kick your asses.
She is so good.
I mean, she's an
unbelievable cook.
And then when she came,
she refused to cook.
Because I served her dinner
the first day she came in.
She tasted the food.
She goes, I can taste
that it's Moroccan,
but I don't recognize it.
I don't know how you did it.
So that was the best compliment.
Because to me the
fear has always
been am I getting too
far away from my roots.
Am I just making food that
everybody else is making.
And there was a struggle there.
Because initially, when you
start thinking about food
and asking why is
it made this way
rather than just let's just
make food that tastes good.
In Morocco, the
best chefs are those
who can make you taste
food, and it takes you back
in time to when you
were a little kid,
or you were growing up with
your grandma, and you can say,
oh, it tastes exactly like
that person used to make it.
That's success for a great chef.
When I came to America, I
realized that a lot of people
are more interested in
what's going to be done.
Who's doing the most
innovative things.
Who's mixing this with that.
Who's doing something that
I've never had before.
That aspect of discovery
is really huge in America,
especially on the coasts,
California and New York.
In Morocco, they
don't care about that.
What they care about,
make me something
that is going to
take me back in time.
That is the epitome of a
great chef or a great dish.
So when she came, she was
able to taste those flavors,
but she had no idea
how it was made.
And to me, that was
the best compliment.
And obviously, she did not
do anything for three months.
When she was staying
with me, she did not
cook anything whatsoever.
She deserved it, because she
cooked for me for 17 years.
So let's get on to some cooking.
The first thing I'm
going to show you
is how to make preserved lemons
and how to make couscous.
Couscous, I think, to me, is
one of the greatest dishes
that I brought from Morocco.
When I first came
to the States, I
was petrified when I saw the
little boxes in the rice aisle,
at Safeway and Whole Foods.
And you just-- you pick it
up, and I was so excited.
I always liked
hand-rolled couscous,
but then you read
the directions,
and it literally says add
boiling water, and that it.
That's couscous.
So I was excited.
Like, Americans are so smart.
They figured this shit out.
And then I followed
the directions,
and it was so awful.
It was like it had absolutely
nothing to do with the couscous
that I grew up with.
I thought I messed it up.
And we got other boxes,
and I stopped making it.
It never worked.
So obviously, that
was frustrating.
And hand rolling couscous
is almost like making pasta.
And it was the hardest
chapter to write in the book.
Because it's one of those things
where it's so simple when you
make it from start to finish.
It's so simple.
Once you get it, you get it.
It's like riding a bicycle.
You don't even think about it.
You get on the bicycle,
you don't even say OK.
These are the dynamics.
This is the physics of it.
You don't even think about that.
You get on the
bicycle, and you roll.
Couscous is like that.
You will fail, fail, fail, fail,
and you will fall on your ass.
You have to get up
again and do it again.
It would be clumpy, it would
be mushy, it would be this,
it would be that.
It would be so inconsistent,
but eventually, you will get it.
And it just happens like that.
I can't explain it.
So to put that into words,
it was the hardest chapter
to write.
Because it has a
lot to do with feel.
It has a lot to do
with understanding.
And you talk to yourself
when you make couscous.
It's virtually
impossible to be engaged
in a lot of conversation
and discussion
with other people around you.
You have to be talk--
Like, you're making
it, and you're rolling
couscous in this big clay pot.
And then you have to--
the granules from the semolina
are touching your hand,
and you feel the edges.
So do you guys know
about coarse semolina?
It comes from durum wheat.
So it's basically a
really hard wheat.
And you crack it, and
it has to be coarse.
So when he's crushed--
I wish we had some visuals--
you have pieces of
semolina that have
all these angles and a lot of
surfaces, like little diamonds.
And when you see
couscous, you want
to avoid the contact
between the semolina.
So if you have two
pieces of semolina that
have surfaces like this,
and there's touching,
there's a lot of
contact, and that's
what makes semolina and
couscous stick together,
and they become clumpy.
So the idea of
rolling couscous is
to get the biggest
pieces of semolina.
And then you roll them
with flour and water,
and you keep rolling them
and making these spheres
to basically even out the edges.
And when you have two
spheres, the point of contact
is just one instead of
the pieces, all the pieces
connecting like this.
You have the couscous basically
touching on only one point,
and that's what keeps it fluffy.
That's what makes the steam go
through all the little spheres
and cook it without having
to glue it together.
So there's a lot of science in
it, but we don't understand.
I mean, we don't think about it.
But when I start
cooking that stuff,
I am asking myself why
certain things happen.
Rather than just making them
the way we used to make them,
I want to understand
what was going on.
So basically, we started
with coarse semolina.
We're not going to
do the demo for how
to make couscous from scratch.
But you start with
coarse semolina.
You roll it.
You dry it overnight.
And then that's what you get.
You get something that
is very similar to this.
And if you're really,
really good at it,
all the spheres should be
approximately the same size,
so when you steam
them, you don't end up
with some that are bigger,
that will take longer,
and some that are smaller,
that will get mushy.
So it's just a scale, and it
takes a little bit of time.
And you have the
book, so please,
just take the time to
read it, and don't give up
if you fail the first time.
It's a fun thing.
You can do it and laugh at
yourself and with your friends
and whatever.
And you can always turn
it into polenta, you know?
If it gets mushy or clumpy,
just add water or stock
and make it into polenta,
and nobody will even notice.
So just go at it.
So we figured out a
way at the restaurant
to make it just a
little bit faster.
So you can see here, this
is the hand-rolled couscous.
And what we do is we use
a little bit of stock.
This is vegetable stock.
And depending on
what you're going
to use the couscous with,
the couscous in itself,
every little grain, every little
sphere, it's so insignificant.
It's nothing.
You can put it in your mouth.
It doesn't taste like
anything by itself.
You can't tell
the texture of it.
But together, it comes
together as being this really
great thing.
And we eat couscous once a
week in Morocco, on Fridays.
Because everybody goes to
the mosque before lunch.
Everybody comes back home.
And then you eat this couscous.
And there's this story
where every single grain
is a step closer to heaven.
So people on Friday, they
really want to go to heaven.
So they just go pray,
come back home on time,
and just sit together,
and then they eat.
And for each grain
that you consume,
it's one step further to heaven.
For each grain that somebody
else consumes that you made.
So we'd make two platters,
one for us at the house,
and one to give away at
the mosque for poor people.
For each grain that they
consume, it's two steps closer.
So people tend to be more
giving than what they actually
keep at home.
So there's a lot
of intellectualism
behind the couscous.
It's not just like it's a side
dish or anything like that.
There's a lot of stories
and a lot of mythology
that goes into it.
So this is the couscous.
And as I said, if you
want to make couscous
with some seafood,
then what I do
is this is a coucoussier, which
is basically a two-part vessel.
The bottom part is
just like any pot.
It basically has
liquid, vegetables,
or any meat that you want
to cook with the couscous.
On the top part is where
you steam the couscous.
So basically, the steam--
we don't make a stock,
per se, in Morocco.
We don't make stocks.
We always cook-- we
start with water.
But the bottom
part is the braise.
So basically, the vegetables.
So you make your own
stock as you cook.
Then the meat goes in
there, and all the things
that are going to be
mounded on the couscous
will basically be at the
lower part, the wet stuff.
And then the couscous
will be on top.
And the idea is to
cook the couscous
and flavor it with whatever
you're going to serve it with.
So if it's seafood,
I tend to put--
so if I break down a fish,
I'll put the bones and the tail
and the fins in there.
If I'm doing chicken, I'll
do the wings and the feet
and the head and all the scraps
and trim from the chicken.
If it's lamb, I'll do the
bones and the fat and all that.
It will be here at the bottom.
The one thing in Morocco that
we do, and I've always question
this, is when you cook
couscous in Morocco,
it's not about the
meat or the vegetables.
So people are so poor in
Morocco that the main thing
on the plate is never the meat.
It's always the vegetable,
the sauce, and the bread
that you eat it with.
So here in America, it's
the other way around.
Where you go to a
restaurant, and you
get a plate that is probably
bigger than this, and half of
it is protein.
It's a 28 ounce steak.
It's a whole chicken.
It's this and that.
So for us, we don't like
to eat a lot of-- well,
it's not like we don't
like to eat a lot of meat.
We can't afford a lot of
meat, to buy a lot of meat.
So we take the meat, and we try
to extract as much flavor as
possible out of it.
We like the hard parts,
like the shoulder
and the leg and the
knuckles and all of that.
Nobody cares about
the rack of lamb.
So for me, when I came here,
and I saw that the rack of lamb
was like $25 a pound, I
was like, this is crazy.
It has the least
amount of flavor.
It's tender, it's
clean, it looks pretty.
It looks-- you know, it's
like perfect for Instagram.
But it's literally like--
the shoulder has so
much more flavor,
because of the connective
tissue, because of the fat,
because of the bones,
because of the kind of meat.
It's so gelatinous.
And the ratio of fat and
skin and connective tissue
is so perfect.
So if you go to a
butcher in Morocco,
you actually have to be
a really good customer
to get the shoulder.
And if you're a bad
customer, you're
going end up with the
rack of lamb or the chops.
So the one thing is we try to
extract as much as possible
from the proteins,
and to do that,
we cook it for a
long period of time,
which is something that people
cannot afford to do in America,
because everybody works.
You have 30 minutes to
make your food and eat it
and all of that stuff.
But in Morocco, we
have a lot of time,
and it takes three hours
to extract the flavor.
So what we're going to do
is I'm going to show you,
first of all, how to
do the couscous the way
we do it at the restaurant.
And for this simple
preparation, I'm
just going to start with
the vegetable stock.
It's just made with water
and aromatics and vegetables.
You've got carrots,
celery, and onions.
And basically what
I'm going to do--
so this is already made.
And this is the
hand-rolled couscous.
I'm going to take one of these.
And you just put the hand-rolled
couscous in a mixing bowl.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any brands you trust?
MOURAD LAHLOU: You know,
[? Justeau's ?] has
really good couscous.
I would buy [? Justeau's ?] if
I were to buy it from the store.
Anson Mills also has
really good couscous,
and they use really good
products, which is really cool.
So yeah, those are
the two that I would--
Mideast.
I think there's a brand in
the market called Mideast.
They tend to be really bad.
So I would avoid those.
So we heat up the veg
stock to a slow simmer,
then we'll let it rest.
I'm going to add a
little bit of saffron,
for the color and the flavor.
Olive oil.
And some salt.
And you can see that
the recipe is so exact.
All the grams are in my head.
And you can also--
for people in Morocco
that use saffron,
it's a sign of affluence.
That means that
you're really rich,
and you make a lot of money.
So even poor people
will kill themselves
when they have guests
to go get saffron.
For most people, what
we use is turmeric.
It has some flavor, but
it's not the same flavor.
And I actually prefer it.
So you can use a
combination of both,
or you can use just the saffron
if you want to impress anybody,
or you can just
use the turmeric.
And turmeric right
now is really hot
because of the new discovered
health benefits to it.
Yeah.
So everybody is
fucking using turmeric.
So once it gets to a little
simmer, and you can see it,
ideally, you want to
let it sit for about--
you can see a little
steam coming out.
You want to let it sit for
about half an hour to infuse it
and get the flavor
out of the saffron.
So we're just going to
accelerate this process.
Then I'm going to
add the couscous
and the infusion together
and literally just
give them a little stir.
And when Chef [? DeMare ?]
makes this at the restaurant,
he always uses a spoon,
and he never, ever
puts his hands in the couscous.
Right, Chef [? DeMare? ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MOURAD LAHLOU: Yeah.
So you can see the couscous
is really like-- it's fluffy.
It's not clumped up.
It's not sticking together.
And I'm going to let this
sit for about 15 minutes, 20
minutes, just so
that the couscous can
absorb all the moisture.
And one thing about
gluten, it's very sticky.
It's very starchy.
So when people just use a
tremendous amount of liquid
with the couscous, that starch
is going to come out really
quickly.
And the heat helps it come out.
If you do the steaming
part instead of just adding
boiling water, if you
steam it, the starch
does not get out
all at once, and you
can contain it a little bit.
So at this point,
we're just going
to pretend that the couscous
has been sitting there
for a few minutes.
And obviously, in Morocco,
we don't have plastic gloves.
So I just want to be sanitary.
But fuck it, man.
No.
That's how we do it.
So basically, all
you do is you go in,
and you literally
separate all the grains.
And this takes a little minute.
And if you can have--
if there's little clumps
that really are difficult,
and you don't have time
to-- just put them aside.
Get rid of them.
Until the whole
thing is pretty much
loose and ready to
go into the steamer.
The steamer, over there at the
bottom, we just have water.
And I'm just going to add some
carrots, celery, and onions.
So it's going to be a very
clean tasting couscous.
AUDIENCE: What's the general
gluten development goal?
Is it like there's gluten,
you have to deal with it.
You want to try to minimize it.
You're trying to not
worry about overworking
it to create more gluten?
MOURAD LAHLOU:
You can't really--
I mean, this is what I'm saying.
It's a feel thing.
So if you really squeeze it
together, it will clump up.
But if you just literally just
rub it between your hands,
everything will fall
down back to the bowl,
but you're going to
be left with these.
I usually will work these
to get them smaller.
But now I'm just going to
do it a little bit quicker,
so that we can
expedite this process.
But the idea is-- the
whole thing is gluten.
I mean, we tried to
make buckwheat couscous.
It was disgusting.
I think David Kinch, who
worked with Marty as well, he
was from [INAUDIBLE].
He called me about
five or six years ago,
and he was really
interested in developing
some sorts of couscous
that doesn't have gluten.
But I don't think
he was successful.
I mean, shit happens
for some reason,
and this is what it
works the best way.
And we tried a couple
of things, but we always
end up going back to this.
So as you can see,
I'm just going
to take a little bit here.
That is pretty cool.
You can see, it's really loose.
It's not like what you
would get if you were just
to pour boiling water on it.
So we're going to pretend that
this whole thing is loose,
and then we're going to
go into the second part.
So for the water, we have water.
We have celery.
And again, you can see
how precise this is.
And another thing
that I want to talk
about, you guys
can all see this,
I'm sure you guys have
these two components
in your kitchen somehow.
This is just a strainer,
and this is a pot.
And you just want to make sure
that the bottom of this steamer
does not touch the water.
So there's plenty
of water in there.
I'm just going to add the
carrots, celery, and onions.
Bring it to a boil.
And then once it
comes to a boil,
I will just take the couscous
and put it in the steamer.
And this will steam for about--
the way we do it, it will
steam for about an hour.
And we'll take it out.
So this is going to look like
shit on video, because it
has all these clumps.
But we're just going to
pretend that they're not here.
So this will steam
for about an hour.
Once it's steamed, we'll take
it into a big mixing bowl,
and we're going to fluff
it again and get rid
of the clumps, and then
put it back in there.
So you get rid of all the
heat from it, you put it back,
and you restart again
for another 15 minutes.
Take it out.
And you do it four times.
And after four times,
four steamings,
that's when you get
the right couscous.
This is couscous that has been
steamed three times already.
And you can see it
doubles in size.
So from the little grains
that we had, these.
From the little spheres
to this is double in size.
So it absorbed all the
liquid and all the moisture
that we wanted it to absorb.
And basically, it's all loose.
And Chef [? DeMare ?]
did a really good job
at separating all of these.
So what I'm going to do, I'm
going to put it back in here,
in the big steamer.
This is the traditional
Moroccan steamer.
And this will steam for
another 15, 20 minutes.
And this will be
part of the couscous
we're going to serve you.
So couscous in itself does
not have a lot of flavor,
but it becomes a vehicle for
adding a lot of flavor to food.
So whatever you
serve couscous with,
that's what's going
to be emphasized.
One of my favorite
ways to eat couscous
is basically with brown
butter and preserved lemons.
That is the simplest way to
eat couscous and enjoy it.
We get a little bit too
technical at the restaurant
with preparations and dishes.
We change them seasonally.
I'm going to show you
a way that we do it
right now for a tasting menu,
where we do it with pumpkin
because of the season.
And sea urchin and roe.
So we'll do that
in a little bit.
But we're just going to wait
for this couscous to come up.
But as you can see, it's
really a cool process.
It's very meditative.
And when you do it, it
takes a couple hours,
but it's really
worth it at the end.
Because once you get into
eating really good couscous,
it's really hard and impossible
to go to the box stuff.
AUDIENCE: You don't cover it?
MOURAD LAHLOU: No.
I don't cover it.
A lot of people do
cover it, or they
do cheese cloth, like this
little thing, at the bottom.
Because they're afraid
that the couscous is going
to make it through the holes.
I don't worry about that.
The weight of the
couscous will basically
keep it from going down.
A couple of grains might--
a couple of spheres
might go down to the
water, but who cares.
Any questions, you guys?
AUDIENCE: Is the general
goal of the steaming,
really are you just
trying to cook the starch?
MOURAD LAHLOU: So the
goal of the steaming
is basically to
give it the moisture
that it needs to fluff
up without giving it
the liquid itself.
So it's a gradual
addition of moisture.
So you have this hard piece of--
it's almost like a pasta.
It is a pasta.
So you have this sphere.
You want to give
it as much moisture
as it needs to fluff
up to the fullest,
but you don't want to pour
the liquid directly on it.
So that's why we steam it.
It gets trapped.
So all the steam
that's coming up
is the excess that would have
otherwise gone into the grains
if you were to pour the
water or the liquid in it.
So it's really a cool process.
And I think it's
really ingenious.
I don't know who
invented couscous.
It's very popular
in North Africa.
It's very popular in Europe.
When the Moors invaded Europe,
they took with them couscous.
And that is one
of the things that
stayed with Europe
when the Moors were
kicked back out of Europe.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: What's the purpose
of the third [INAUDIBLE]
MOURAD LAHLOU: It's ready.
It's cold, so we need
just to heat it up.
Yes.
So I would rather give
it to you warm than cold.
So we're just heating it up.
And it's just we figured out the
timing that it needs to cook,
and we just split it,
so that we would never
give it too much steaming at
one time and make it mushy.
So the more periods that
you do it, the better.
It's like with risotto.
You keep adding little by little
rather than just giving it
everything in one shot.
AUDIENCE: And what's the bottom.
It's just water or?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Water, carrots,
onions, bay leaves, thyme.
You can do a lot of aromatics
that you have in the kitchen.
I'll tell you what, if you
don't have to warm it up,
you can just put it in a
pint container like this,
and put it in the microwave,
and it would be awesome.
So this last step, literally,
it's the same couscous,
and you can literally just add
a little bit of stock or water,
put it in the microwave, and
zip it for maybe a minute,
depending on your
microwave, and then
it will be nice and fluffy.
Because I don't know if you
guys use microwaves here,
but it's one of the greatest
inventions of all times.
I have absolutely no
probably using microwaves.
I think they're great.
But when I discovered
that I could use it
to steam couscous for the
last steaming, it was like--
I felt like Einstein.
I really did.
And it comes out
really perfectly.
And the fact that the
pint container is sealed,
there's liquid in
there, and it's
steamed because
of the microwave,
because of the mechanics of it.
And then it steams within
this contained container,
and it's magic.
It's really one of the
greatest inventions.
So while the couscous is going
on, I'm going to move on.
How much time do we have?
AUDIENCE: 20 plus minutes.
MOURAD LAHLOU: OK.
So we're going to move on
to the second greatest thing
that Moroccans have contributed
to the world of food,
and that is preserved lemons.
Growing up in Morocco,
I came from Marrakesh,
where we have a lot of citrus.
And when we have that
must citrus coming out,
and the trees are full, we
don't know what to do with it.
We're not into lemonade, so we
don't make a lot of lemonade.
We don't use lemon
juice, necessarily,
to season stuff, salads
and things like that.
We like vinegars because
they're more fermented,
and they have a deeper
flavor than just lemon juice.
So what we do with
it is we preserve it.
So we harvested the
lemons, took them home,
and the ladies
would get together
around this big container with
all these lemons and a lot
of salt and just big jars, clay
jars, and we preserved lemons.
And the funny thing is I
think the preserved lemon is
one of the most amazing things.
And literally, it
starts from this.
And you get it to this.
What do you think
about preserved lemons?
AUDIENCE: When we
started working together,
it was kind of like
a game changer.
MOURAD LAHLOU: It's
AUDIENCE: Totally
unique, different flavor.
MOURAD LAHLOU: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MOURAD LAHLOU: But
the cool part is
when you juice a lemon, a
regular lemon, when you use it
for dressing or whatever, you
get rid of the pit, the skin.
So that's discarded.
You just-- you're
interested in the juice.
Moroccans, we get
everything backwards.
So we're interested in the
pit, but we don't really
care about the juice.
So the way to make
it, it's really cool.
So let me show you
how to do that.
AUDIENCE: Is this
lacto-fermented?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Yes.
And basically, you can either--
sometimes you can take the
syrup from the previous batch
and re--
yes.
And it's really cool.
And it takes a
little bit longer,
but the results are much better.
So I have just
kosher salt, here.
And you can see,
there's a lot of it.
If you really want
to cheat, and you
think that it's
too salty for you,
and I'm going to give you--
Chef [? DeMare, ?]
can we give everybody
a little sample of
the preserved lemons,
so they can taste it by itself?
Yes.
Here.
Why don't you take this?
Maybe you can just give
them little spoons.
Because I really think
it's one of the best things
that came out of Morocco.
So we use a lot of salt.
And then with a knife, you--
and I don't like to
use Meyer lemons.
To me, they don't have enough
acid to cure the lemons,
and they're sweeter.
So it doesn't work
for me at all.
I do a quick preserve
cure for Meyer lemons,
but it's just like
a day, overnight.
And I slice them really
thin, and I sprinkle them
with salt and sugar.
And the next day, they're
perfect for salads.
But to get the best
preserved lemons,
you use Eureka lemons or Lisbon.
They're really good.
So you can see, you
send it on its butt,
and you make two
cuts lengthwise.
But you don't cut them
all the way through.
Because what you need is to
be able to stuff as much salt
as possible.
It's never enough.
And then we take a jar--
AUDIENCE: But you're not
aiming for 2% or 3% salt?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Pardon me?
AUDIENCE: You're not aiming
for a certain percent salt?
MOURAD LAHLOU: No.
And that's what's really
cool about Moroccan cooking.
It's never-- there's no recipes.
There's just a way of
cooking that is handed down
from one generation to another.
And some of the best
cooks in Morocco
are these ladies who work in
very affluent homes, where
they can get paid.
And basically, they have
recipes in their heads
of how to cook certain things.
And they're the best chefs.
There's no doubt about it.
They're called dadas.
Big ladies.
You know, they spend a lot
of time in the kitchen.
And they're so seasoned.
But they love what they do.
And basically, those
ladies would never
give recipes to anybody, no
matter who they are, except
for their daughters.
Because they want to make sure
that one of their daughters
will get the job
after they pass.
And it just stays in the family
from generation to generation.
And most of them, when
you ask them for recipes,
they'll always give
you the wrong stuff.
Always.
So nobody even asks.
So we're going to shove as many
lemons as possible in there.
That sounds like my restaurants.
I always freak out
when I hear that sound.
And once you put the lemons
with the salt in there,
you can leave the jar
sealed for about a day.
And a lot of the juice from
the lemons will be extracted,
and this jar will probably
be half full of juice.
And that's what we want.
So I just seal it.
Put it away for a day.
The juice will come up to here.
You shake it really well,
and then after one day,
I'll squeeze some lemon
juice, and I will fill it
all the way to the top.
So we're just going
to pretend that this
is all the way to the top.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MOURAD LAHLOU: No.
No.
And you're putting it away for
about three months, at least.
You can use it after one month.
It will not taste
anything like lemon.
But the most important
ingredient in this preparation
is time.
You need to have
the time to do it.
You can't rush it.
There's no way you can--
we tried to do a
sous vide, where you
expedite the process of cure--
it doesn't work.
It really doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: What's the longest
you've kept lemons [INAUDIBLE]
MOURAD LAHLOU: We
have preserved lemons
right now that are
five years old.
And they look
black, almost black.
They go from yellow to
orange, and they start
getting darker and darker.
They literally
turn almost black.
They're intense.
I'll give you some
when you come up.
So this stays somewhere cold
and dark for about a month.
You can use it after a month.
I don't recommend it.
Anywhere between three months
to six months is ideal.
And then when you're
done, you end up
with something like this.
So you can't juice these.
And you can see, it's all soft.
The most important
part is the pit.
So basically, you
clean the core.
And I use the whole thing.
I use the whole thing.
Once you make these,
they're the best presence.
You can make them
now for Christmas,
and people will be so happy.
They will think you love them so
much because you took the time
to do this.
So the most important part
of this preserved lemon
is this part.
So this is what we
use at the restaurant.
You can slice it and
put it in salads.
You can put it on top of steaks.
You can dice it and mix
it in with couscous.
It is literally something
that you will never
be able to live without.
It's that simple.
It's that cheap.
And you can make it when
lemons are really cheap
and not have to worry about it
for a whole year or two years.
So if there's anything you guys
can get away from this class,
it's go home and make some
fucking preserved lemons.
It is so delicious.
And I'm going to give you
some little bit to taste.
I think Chef [? DeMare ?]
is doing that.
And then the other
part is, you can see,
we don't throw this away.
This is the core.
So what I do with these, they're
salty, as you can imagine.
They're acidic.
They have some tartness.
You put them in stews.
So you just take
a couple of these,
put them in stews or braises or
your pasta sauce or whatever.
People will think
you're a genius.
Oh my god.
What did you do?
Iron Chef is like, it's a
Japanese technique that I came
across when I went to Japan.
But it's fucking
preserved lemons.
It's like plain and simple.
It's preserved lemons.
And then the last part that
is really important, this
is lemon juice that's
been sitting there
for a couple of months.
It's going to get salty.
It's going to get
really thick, and it's
going to change in color.
It's going to become clearer.
It's not going to be as cloudy.
And it's delicious.
So instead of using
salt, straight up salt,
you can use that liquid
to season your salads.
So you can see how you
can use the whole thing.
And I literally
cannot emphasize this.
And Marty has worked
with me for a long time.
We've known each
other for many years.
If there is one thing
that I want anybody
to take away from this,
it's this little thing here.
And the hardest part about it--
anybody can do it.
It's not couscous.
It's not hand rolling couscous.
That is really hard
to get to a point
where you're comfortable with it
and it works out all the time.
This is so simple.
So you have
absolutely-- you have
zero-- if you guys work at
Google, you can do this shit.
I'm telling you.
So it's not that hard.
AUDIENCE: And keeping them
intact to be able to use them
decoratively, maybe, or
why not just break them
down smaller so [INAUDIBLE].
MOURAD LAHLOU: So once
they get to a point--
and that is a great question.
Once they get to a point when
I'm really happy with them,
if the purpose is to use
them on a daily basis,
I would let them
get to this point.
So what I do at that
point, if I just
let them sit in
the syrup longer,
they'll get darker
and more intense.
So I take them out, rinse
them off in cold water,
and then I will get this
part and just slice it,
or I can chop it.
And I think we have a
little sample somewhere.
Chef [? DeMare, ?] can
I have the chopped up,
preserved lemons?
And then we stop the curing
part by adding the olive oil.
So the oil will stop everything.
And they will stay the
way-- at this stage,
they will stay like
that for a few months.
There's no problem.
So rinsing them off and
taking them off of the liquid
will stop that curing
process, and then you
end up with
preserved lemons that
will be the same
consistency, the same flavor.
And the oil that you put in to
mix them with, it's amazing.
So once you're done with
the preserved lemons,
you're left with a
really flavorful--
literally, some of
the best olive oil.
So I'm going to give you guys--
the ones that are
sitting up front--
you get to taste some
of this stuff, here.
Is it legal to do this?
AUDIENCE: Go for it.
MOURAD LAHLOU: The
health department--
AUDIENCE: The audience
questions, we'll
just fire away at you.
MOURAD LAHLOU: --I can
just take one of these.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How has
refrigeration changed the taste
of of preserved lemons.
MOURAD LAHLOU: We don't
like refrigeration
with this process.
It needs to be at room temp.
If you put it in
the refrigerator,
the temperature is so
low, it literally almost
stops that whole
process of curing.
So.
AUDIENCE: Have you
tried the same technique
with grapefruits or
other types of citrus?
MOURAD LAHLOU: We tried to
be creative with this stuff,
but it doesn't work.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't work.
MOURAD LAHLOU: No.
Limes don't work, because
the pith is not thick enough.
A grapefruit is too thick, and
it just becomes spongy and not
very flavorful.
I think it's the acid and the
level of tartness and acidity
in the lemons that
makes them so perfect.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
measure the PH for--
MOURAD LAHLOU: That's
too complicated, man.
That's like Google stuff.
SPEAKER: You are
at Google, though.
Other audience questions?
We have a few minutes.
I've got plenty of
questions for Chef,
but I'd love to open
it up to the audience.
So if you have a
question, we'll ask
Chef Mourad to
repeat the question
so we can get this
on the video end.
So any burning questions?
AUDIENCE: Just
one last question.
So you talked about [INAUDIBLE]
MOURAD LAHLOU: We get
up in the morning,
we stuff our faces at 7:30.
Then we go to work or to school.
We literally don't eat
anything until 12:30,
when we come back for lunch.
And then people take a nap
then go back to work or school.
And then they come
back for dinner.
But the main meal is lunch.
It's never dinner.
So dinner is like leftover
from lunch or a little snack.
So no, there's no snacks.
And I just came back from
Morocco three weeks ago.
I went there for nine days.
And I ate so much.
And sometimes we
had two dinners,
because there's so
many people to see
that I have an early
dinner about 7 o'clock,
and a late dinner at 10
o'clock, because I just
want to see all my family
members and friends
and make everybody happy.
And when I came
back, I was like, oh.
OK.
Mourad from America.
I came back, and I
was like, oh my god.
I've gotta get on a
scale, because I probably
gained 10 pounds.
I lost weight when I was
eating all that food.
And I literally think it's
the quality of the food.
When I first came to America,
people were freaking out about,
like, OK, we go to the farmer's
market as if it's some luxury.
Like, the whole world goes to
the farmer's market every day.
That's the way it is.
So now going to the farmer's
market is the weird part.
It's not the other way around.
So when people go to the
farmer's market on Saturday,
and they buy a peach for
like $5.00, oh my god,
that's like a crazy idea.
That's what happens.
And usually, the
farmer's markets
all over the world,
most of the world,
is cheaper than the
market, because you're
eliminating the middleman.
For some reason, in America,
it's the other way around,
where you can buy a peach that
is really healthy for $5.00
at the market, but you can
buy a lot of food from a store
for a lot less.
But that's the mass
production of food.
It's all screwed up.
The whole thing is screwed up.
So we've got to rethink
the whole process.
OK.
So we've got to rush a
little bit through this.
The last thing I want
to do for you guys
is show you how to make
couscous in the simplest way.
What I do-- and if
I were to die today,
the last thing I
would love to eat
is couscous with brown butter.
For all of you who are
really health conscious
and think that fat
is bad, maybe this
is not the part you
should be looking at.
So I have a pot here, and
I have some brown butter.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
We put a lot of brown--
I mean, let's just do it right.
So that is for
probably one portion.
We heat up the brown butter.
If you make brown
butter from scratch
while you are making
this, you can just
put the butter in a pot,
bring it up, let it cook off.
The milk solids will brown.
The liquid will evaporate,
and the whey will evaporate.
So you're left with
fat and milk solids
that are browning in there.
So it's the most
delicious thing.
Do you like brown butter?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MOURAD LAHLOU: OK.
You're lying.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MOURAD LAHLOU: Just butter.
Yeah.
So I'm going to add a little
bit of the preserved lemons,
just to infuse it.
A little bit of
salt. And you need
to be careful with this
stuff with the salt,
because the preserved
lemons are salty.
So you've just got
to play it off.
And as soon as it starts to
foam, I'll take the couscous,
add it in.
And then guess what's
going to happen?
The couscous is going to
absorb all that butter,
and nobody would know.
AUDIENCE: What kind
of butter do you use?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Just
unsalted butter.
Because you need to be--
I mean, every time
you buy salted butter,
you're basically paying $8.00
for salt. $8.00 a pound.
Because every gram is added
to the weight of the butter
that you buy.
So you can just
add your own salt,
and you don't have to
pay that much for it.
So this is pretty
much ready to go.
And at the restaurant, what
we do to keep it seasonal,
we have some pumpkin that's
been roasted and diced.
So we're going to
add that to couscous.
Take it off the heat.
We have a small plate, here.
And at the restaurant, we use--
right now we're using
uni and roe, smoked roe.
AUDIENCE: Where do you look for
inspiration for how you enhance
the couscous? the couscous?
[INAUDIBLE] roe and uni
and traditional Moroccan?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Absolutely not.
Absolutely not.
I mean, the way we
eat couscous, as I
was saying at the beginning.
I don't know if I
emphasized that point.
The way we use it in
Morocco is literally
overcooked meat, overcooked
vegetables, but the grain,
the couscous is the
most important part,
and people just eat it by hand.
You would [INAUDIBLE],, make
a little bowl, and flip it
in your mouth.
But at the restaurants, we try--
whenever we use
couscous as an entree,
we try to cook the
vegetables separately.
The proteins are cooked
separately, if we ever
use proteins with it.
But for this, it's
just an idea of--
to me, it's almost
like rice in Japan,
where you have a vehicle.
If you talk to a
lot of sushi chefs,
they'll say that
cooking the rice
is the most important
part of sushi.
And most people don't
think of it that way.
They think about the
fish and how unique it is
and how scarce it is and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But most chefs in
Japan will literally
tell you the most
important part is the rice.
I felt the same way about this.
So I can put uni.
I can put roe.
I can put merguez,
which is a lamb sausage.
I can put beef stew,
a piece of fish,
it doesn't really matter to me.
The couscous is the
most important part.
But it's such a clean
vehicle for anything,
that you can literally use it.
But I think the most
important part is
the grain, but also the butter.
The butter.
And nobody will complain
about the butter.
So we'll use some uni with this.
This is Japanese
uni from Hokkaido.
And just sprinkle it
all over the place.
And just to impress you
guys, this is not as much
as we use at the restaurant.
So if you come to
the restaurant,
and you see two
little tongues on it,
that's because it's
really expensive.
And then the roe.
And just to finish
it off, and this
is what makes us justify
charging people what we charge,
we just put a lot of blossoms.
Here we go.
And flowers.
And there's your
$30.00 couscous.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions, you guys?
SPEAKER: So I'll start
with the first question.
And we've got a few for
questions, if you have them.
So Chef, you've been on TV.
You've written a book.
You've got restaurants
that you're running.
What is your proudest moment,
that you could think back,
that you want to share
with the audience today?
MOURAD LAHLOU: The proudest
from a professional level
or from a personal level?
SPEAKER: Why not both?
One of each.
MOURAD LAHLOU: Personal
level is when my mom came,
and I was really
expecting her to school us
on how to make Moroccan food.
And the biggest fear that
I had was for her to say,
this is not Moroccan food.
That was like the biggest
nightmare that I was imagining.
But when she said, my god,
this tastes like back home.
This reminds me of back home,
that was the first moment when
I felt that food
is really like-- it
has to have a sense of place.
If you were to go to Morocco,
to where I grew up, Marrakesh,
and go to the night market,
called [NON-ENGLISH],,
which is all this sweet food,
and you would eat a bite
of anything there, it will taste
so much better and so much more
delicious than if you were
to take the same exact bite
and eat it in San Francisco
near the Golden Gate Bridge.
It just doesn't add.
So for me, food has to
have a sense of place.
So when she said
that, it allowed
me to think that I brought
something from Morocco,
and I made it fit this
environment, where
it had a sense of place.
So that was a very proud moment.
Professionally, I
think when we first
got the Michelin star at Aziza,
it was very sweet for me.
But it just happened
to be on the same year
that two of my best friends,
James Syhabout was from Commis,
and Jeremy Fox from
Ubuntu at the time,
got it also at the same time.
And Marty was working
at Ubuntu at the time.
So he was responsible
for that star as well.
So when we all get that
star the same year,
it was the sweetest moment
of my professional career.
To this day.
SPEAKER: That's very special.
Thank you.
Any audience questions?
MOURAD LAHLOU: How
many people are going
to go back and make couscous?
SPEAKER: How many
people are going
to try to grab that
plate in front?
MOURAD LAHLOU: How
about preserved lemons?
All right.
Well then, I did my job.
Anyways.
SPEAKER: Chef,
one last question.
So you have a new restaurant
coming on board tomorrow.
Can you talk a
little bit about that
and how that will be
different from what
you've done in the past?
MOURAD LAHLOU: Yeah.
So we had Aziza for
18 years, and it
was one of the most special
restaurants in the country.
It started out as
this idea of me just
making a place for
myself to go eat
when I'm going to conquer the
world and make a lot of money.
And it turned into--
It was so organic, and it went
through so many phases, where
initially it was a place
where I would recreate
the dishes that I
grew up on and I was
eating when I was a little boy.
And then when I saw the
limitations of that,
we started to
experiment a little bit.
We started to ask, why are
we making couscous this way?
Why are we making this
stew with this sauce?
[INAUDIBLE] sauce,
blah blah blah.
But we start to peel away all
those mysteries of why Moroccan
food was the way it was.
And then when we
started to experiment,
that's when I met Marty.
And we started to add stuff from
California, from the Bay Area,
to my food and take
it to a new direction.
And then eventually,
as Mourad, we
ended up summing up all
those experiences and journey
into that one spot.
So Aziza became this place
that was really unique.
It was selected as
one of the 30 most
important restaurants in the
country over the last 30 years.
And people had a really strong
connection with that place.
It was not just the food,
but for some reason, people
when they go to
Aziza, they really
have a soft spot for
where they used to sit,
or where the bar was, or I
proposed to my girlfriend
on that table, I had
my 18th birthday here.
So people had stories.
They did not just
go there to eat.
And I was not--
I mean, I heard about that
shit, but I really didn't--
it didn't add up in my head.
But when we opened the Mourad.
And the Mourad was a
really expensive project,
people started to
compare the two.
Aziza is neglected.
Mourad is the new fancy place.
And I really want to
do something for Aziza
so it doesn't get forgotten.
So we decided to remodel it.
And we thought it was going to
cost a couple hundred thousand
dollars and two months.
Now it's two and a half years
later and a few million dollars
later.
But the reason
why it's not going
to be called Aziza anymore,
it's not going to be Aziza,
is because the city made
us change so many things.
Because it was such
an old building.
There were six elevations
everywhere, steps, ramps,
and all of the EDA
and the new code,
we could not do
any of that stuff.
So a lot of walls
needed to move.
The bar needed to move.
I really felt like
people, if they
were to come into that
building and know it as Aziza,
it would never have a
chance to be successful,
because people are going to
be upset that they don't have
their favorite table
where it used to be,
and blah, blah, blah.
So we decided to come up with
a concept that made more sense.
I worked with a lot of
Guatemalans when I had Aziza.
And I remember, every time
I would make something new,
they would taste it,
and they would say,
oh, we used to have
this in Guatemala,
or we used to have
this in the Yucatan.
I was like, you're full of
shit, because this is typically
Moroccan food.
But there was a lot
of intersections,
but I never paid
attention to them.
So finally, one of my sous
chefs and CDCs from Aziza,
he's half Mexican.
And he worked with me
for a while at Aziza.
But when he came back,
after he got divorced,
he came back to
work with me again.
We were talking
about the concept.
And the initial idea was
to make Aziza come back,
but it just didn't feel right.
I really lost a lot
of sleep over it.
And I decided, OK.
What we can do is explore
that moment in time
when the Moors invaded Europe.
And that happened in 711.
It has nothing to do with
the Middle Eastern stores,
like the 7-Eleven stores.
711, the year 711, the
Moors invaded Europe.
They were there for 800 years.
So they brought with them a
lot of food, a lot of art,
a lot of literature, all
of that stuff stayed there
for 800 years.
When they were
kicked out in 1492,
that was the same year that the
Europeans discovered America.
And when America, the New
World, was discovered,
a lot of the Moors
that were kicked out
of the country and the
ones that stayed in Europe,
they were made into slaves that
were brought to Latin America
to work the land and basically
push away the natives.
But the slaves that were
brought to the New World
brought a lot of
spices with them,
a lot of technique from
the Moorish culture.
And I want to explore that
one moment in time in 1492
when those two
cultures intersected,
and I just want to put a
little bit of light on that
and see how the spices,
and the act of frying
was foreign to Latin America.
It was brought-- you know.
And if you think about Al
pastor, taco al pastor,
it's meat that is cooked
vertically on a stick.
And it rotates,
and they slice it.
That's a gyro.
I mean, I'm sorry.
It's a gyro.
So if you take the two,
there's a lot of similarities.
So that's what we
want to explore.
I'm not-- I mean, don't expect
to have a couscous burrito,
because it's not
going to happen.
But we just want to explore
that idea of where the two
cultures intersected
and put an emphasis
on the spices, the
technique, and the harmony
in those two things.
SPEAKER: Chef,
thank you so much.
MOURAD LAHLOU: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Give him a
round of applause.